this gent has got his own podcast now
two in the bush podcast
uh along with sasha boggs
available wherever you get your podcasts
drops every monday
our buddy tom arnold back here on the
rich hazard show how are you thomas
i'm good buddy how you doing man how are
you i am doing great
i am doing better for talking to you
well
that's good um was your show on tv
today i don't know with nbcsn
there's there's there's people playing
soccer there's there's people bite you
know biking in france
i see biking there's like a fast forward
bike yeah maybe i put it in fast forward
when was the last time you went on a
what was the last time you rode a bike
tom i uh two days ago with my kids a
little bike
i could do it so you should get out of
it okay and a lot of that
so your father of the year is what
you're saying you did it yeah i really
am well i don't know i kept about pretty
late moving my assistant
in a pretty bad neighborhood so baby
father of the year
okay fantastic adam go down to start the
car for me
down in koreatown okay get the car ready
to go um
but but pretty much father of the year
you want i
um we were going down memory lane mike
del tufo was going down memory lane
about uh
about best damn sports show period tom
yeah i heard that i want to i want to
help fill in some information there for
you okay i think he was talking about
the
jacksonville super bowl okay if i'm not
right
and uh we went live on the big network
on big fox on big fox you were normally
interested it was a big
biggest opportunity ever and what they
did is they hit up
they pushed a button in uh l.a
and uh it was uh the wrong piece of tape
yep
it was a piece of tape the practice
piece where we did we went down and then
sal started saying
god blanket blanket bank it you stupid
people who go to church on sunday
because it was sunday morning
before the super bowl and you guys are
stupid enough to
that we're here you know it was just
messy we were laughing
because it was the tape we weren't to
use and that's what happened
and then uh you know and they played
that wrong came with the people
especially in the area there you know
they're jacksonville florida of course
well i mean anywhere anywhere tommy i
guess
yeah went to america so uh they got they
got a call because all the bigwigs are
on a boat down there
and uh it was on our uh it was our one
opportunity
to maybe take the show and and move it
up a little bit
and there was just all those swear words
about the stupid people that go to
church
you know they're very sensitive and uh
yeah you know well we had such a great
time we're down there all week
and what i remember the most about the
game was it was a tight game and
and uh and donald mcgavin was
quarterback obviously for the eagles
right
and he was very sick i mean he was very
you know out of his mind and vomiting
and
um they didn't think about the game and
i was down right on the field
and then uh and then tom brady uh we're
going oh my gosh what you know what
should we get on the field what can we
go to
and i couldn't see the clock and my
bardia
go down go and i ran out there and he
just got tackled
for what would be the last play they're
going to run it out
and i got on him literally got on top of
him there's still seven seconds left so
i go
how do you feel i had no questions how
do you feel
i never did and he gets up he starts
talking he goes well
this is so fantastic he starts to unfurl
his body
and then he looks at my microphone then
he looks at me and realize who it is
that they just got to push
my mic out of the way where are the real
journalists
and just watch them but wait and it was
very funny for our show wait
so hold on a second tom arnold um you're
saying
that when tom brady became
to date the last quarterback in the nfl
to win back-to-back
championships something that patrick
mahomes hopes to do later on
the first person he saw with time still
on the clock yeah in jacksonville was
tom arnold with the best damn sports
show period uh
mike cube in front of him that that that
that happened
i i got in very bad trouble for the nfl
and uh i was in the pile i got down
there stuck my bike in
like this is uh by that we had i had no
question to ask you either i never did
okay
steve hill i go uh and then i i remember
with
the locker rooms they saw anthony reid
come out of
his locker room and he started walking
towards us down in long haul and
and uh barty is like you gotta ask
yourself i'm like i am no way
what he just lost the super bowl what do
i ask him what did you lose
how does it feel they're like yeah i go
i'm in no i'm not asking that
no way this is embarrassing i'm gonna
look at the wall but let him walk by me
i'm not gonna ask him he must be so
upset no
and they got by me and i go hey i talked
to your wife she's really nice and
you'll say something it became the
awkward thing because we also had to get
out
the door which was on the other side of
him yeah so it's a long haul walk
and i'm like he watched really nice and
better okay all right
and uh but it's really funny but and
he's also a very nice guy i was so happy
when andy reid wanted superman too
a lot of memories came back you know
well look at least but at least in
what probably has to be to date even um
you know obviously getting um let go by
your team or mutually parting away as
your team is in philadelphia he knew he
had to know that there was something
else coming up for him so you had to be
fine there
the lowest professional moment for him
has to be losing the super bowl at least
you were there to help soften that blow
tom
yeah yeah you know so he still practiced
well i mean
that's a basic thing and he's still in
the super bowl though
he in the super bowl is a big deal yeah
i think no doubt about it no doubt about
it so who is the best
so you got a good deacon story from back
in the day
you know he was uh he was there for day
one man and uh
he was uh you know deacon was always
uh bitter because they didn't get the
account
uh sacks when he first started that's
right and uh and deacon
uh was very he had uh he had narcolepsy
but but it wasn't like official
narcolepsy but he he did
he did he was tired and uh yeah he said
he went to sleep a lot i
uh he literally went to sleep
but he's one of those men they could go
to sleep a lot like
you know uh they could just go to sleep
and it wasn't like it was good because
he
everybody needs to rest but he went to
sleep a lot
he just was one of those guys had that
ability and a lot of times it was on the
show
and uh but he was also he had the energy
he'd get up and
you know but we had to assist with
somebody you know those slave shows
was says that he has the ability to do
one thing yes
and he did he had the ability to slap
people
side of the head and um and so you know
i got slapped a lot besides that he had
giant giant bony fingers huge
he loved to do that as a bit we did wear
helmets we did the first time they got
such a pain to put the helmet on we had
to recreate that hand slap
and then i think towards uh the end of
like the third month
he realized oh michael urban's gonna
replace me so then he then
you know became a little addicted which
i don't blame him yes
and the head slaps is it's like he had
uh
uh these beads they become very heavy
beats because they kind of started
snapping back and
he was a little passive aggressive i
don't even know passive
but he was such a nice guy he had so
much more to do he really had so much
more to do
and i love him uh he also had trouble
remembering
you know people's names or
that was for everybody oh man everybody
they were saying that he's in your ear
like you know you're bob hope or
something like hey this is uh
yeah this is okay that's that's rich
eisen
he's like uh rick tyler uh you know
and uh nobody knew but he was deacon
jones man i mean he's deacon jones i got
tom arnold here yep i love being a joke
so much
yeah oh i love him so much but he was
brilliant he was brilliant
so tell me about your tell me about your
pod tom what's
what listen man i have you i live with
my kids
uh 61 year old uh single dads and
seven-year-olds and
four-year-old and somebody has to help
us here my pa i have this uh
young assistant i always say young
because i'm old right and then she
she ends up uh because the coba is
staying here with me and the kids and
she's ready with my kids we what they
say let's do a podcast nobody's leaving
the area here
she did a podcast she's hilarious she's
a comic
and then but what you end up talking
about is our point of view or
of the comics i like or my career and
what's been the influences on her
and you know i just talk about these
great athletes when i was growing up
you know the day al caitlin died no i
know that's not
but i just said why he was so important
to me just guys like jack can say
they played every day and they just
showed up and you know
things like this and that i talk about
you know the chicago cubs growing up but
that's one guy
dave the ghost hunter that was here we
were talking about how much that meant
to us
and and harry kerry and my other buddies
you know jack buck in southeast iowa
sure the announcers the players how and
that just meant
so much to us and i asked her if there's
anybody like that
in her life and she said uh john mayer
and then
i said it made me so mad that she would
say that
i said why well you know he really i
really felt like he
whatever and it was so stupid you know
john mayer on the
other hand he's a really great guy who
does things but you know
he doesn't represent the chicago cubs
yeah or al k line for that matt argues i
don't even know if he's the only okay
like for sure no
he's not the alkaline musicians i mean
he's good in his own right but i i don't
know
if i really got was upset i mean i took
him
i was scared that i would have to make
her leave the house because
i thought i was like scared like i
brought somebody that just
just could what couldn't even yeah that
i could never speak to again basically
and we're gonna have a podcast so we
have a lot of fun and she is a
she is a character all my friends you
know tish you know i get a call for tish
and he's like
hey what's up baby that's kids good yeah
how are you doing good
you what's the new you and uh sanji
shots was very cute right
well still she uh she just said i go
yeah you know she's my assistant we do
the podcast stuff oh
you guys aren't um i go no no
she's 30 years she's turning yourself
like until you're 37 years old he goes
oh i
i didn't think you so you know with you
well i mean
look tom i mean you i know you go way
back uh with uh
with your buddy steve there and what'd
you think of the giants opener what'd
you think of the giants
hey hey let me tell you something man
let me tell you something you could i've
seen worse
by the way you can't that's
let's put it this way i don't think the
giants are going to make that
the slogan for their 2020 uh team video
you know what i mean yes they're so good
yeah john 20 20 giants hey
we've seen worse you can't you know what
i mean
let's see i'm so happy football's back
me too brother i just was
i was like it i just thought you know
and now our our big chance coming back i
heard
well i hope so too yeah you're mr iowa
hey man look i'm really fired up about
your pod two in the bush podcast
i do watch your show every day good tv
you have a tv show right yes
when they're not cycling but we're on
peacock get peacock and streaming it's
great it's amazing
okay okay i'm doing that thanks rich
you're the voice of football you know
you always are yeah i love you tom you
take care of yourself you guys right
back thanks for having me
you guys it's time everybody it's time
one of a kind hey you watched all the
way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here